samuel what was the biggest shock issue
you had to run in when going into a jv
development anything to safeguard us
against yeah
do you want to talk about that yeah i
will um
i would say i don't go into the details
too
too much but i would just say make sure
that you don't
trust the person that you're going you
go even if they even if they're a
friend and everything you need to get an
airtight contract with a solicitor and
check everything
that's fair always get solicited to drop
your contracts
always have a contract even if you're
family
or buddies because honestly i have
assistance representing
you because people get so greedy
and they see money on the table when the
property starts going up
people just get greedy it's all it's so
sad
because we've never been like that we've
never we weren't raised we weren't
raised that way
um yeah of course we like money
you know absolutely but i'll be just
totally i'm just like
straightforward yeah i want to make
money yeah i won't get money but then
actually
like but people get really greedy
same as it's really sad but you know
when someone um dies
um and they've got money their kids
often will stop fighting and squabbling
over them and it's like what
what and the more money the more they'll
squabble
if it was 50 grand they'll just they'll
squabble over the 50 grand but if it's
if it's 5 million then it's like they're
going to fight for
every single penny and it's really a
and it's just people get like that
sometimes when when you've made a lot of
money choices no big deal i mean we've
been making money for years and years
it's no big deal all right great i made
100 grand there a couple hundred grand
there that's just
that's that's just it and the thing is
it doesn't affect our everyday life
because we we both pay ourselves a
salary out
well ourselves cellular property company
um you've got
several businesses that you set up
before we even we even partnered
together
but the thing is it's just a game it's
like monopoly for us
but for some people it's like oh this is
gonna change my life and people get
really greedy
and that that would be what my answer
alex i would say
um people will get greedy people will
stab you in the back
people will go back on their words when
money's on the table it's sad
it's just the reality of it um and
make sure you've got a really clear
agreement not just for for
a legal agreement but also for
clarification purposes talk about
clarification purposes
um so just being re so in the cold light
of day
just being really before the property
sheets have been valued before
things go good all things go bad the
cold water
is really clear about how we even did it
we did it we
did it when we teamed up you got to do
it you've got to be talking about what
we actually do
we spent about
three months yeah in negotiations when
we when we teamed up
yeah um we'll put it in a book one day
yeah and
we went over everything and you might
say you know oh well
i mean when we started business seven
years ago we'd have just got ah whatever
let's just
have a bash make some money we'll just
split it up and we'll just do what's
fair
but what we've learned is that from
experience
you can't just say oh we'll just cross
that bridge and do what's fair at the
time
you've got to decide everything in the
cold light a day what happens if this
happens and what about this and what
about this and what are we going to do
with this happening
the other good thing about that is you
don't know who who's going to happen to
yep
so if this happens you want to buy me
out what happens i want to buy you out
what happens and you're just doing it in
the cold like a day and then when it
comes to it
you can't you can't say oh wow you know
we never talked about this or i would
have thought
i would have assumed it's like no no we
talked about it and we had it written up
and it's legally binding so that's just
it he's actually added a little bit the
question relates to the site i've told
samuel about on the coast we're doing a
no money down
development backed by an investor um so
we will complete the development so no
money in but it's a circa 350 out
plus the ownership of the lands and one
plot that's great if you're not putting
money in yourself
much less it's much less risky the only
risk you've got if you're not putting
the money in
is you've got the risk of your
reputation if you're putting the money
in
that's when it's like all right and
we've put a lot of money into deals
we've had great joint venture partners
we've had good ones and we've helped the
odd
terrible one um but see i
i want to luckily mostly it's been good
but when you're putting a lot of money
in but if you're not putting any money
and then it's not such an issue because
the worst thing that can happen is what
you lose
a friend and a reputation which is bad
of course
but are you putting him you're putting
in a lot of money then then
so yeah alex sounds great your deal
looks fantastic you sent it to me on
instagram it looks really good i'm
excited
we're happy to walk walk you through
anything you need walking through
alex as well i knew you just joined
samuel 365.
it's part of samuel 365 anyone that's on
this call that doesn't know
you get unlimited mentoring calls talk
talk about that bro yes so
uh basically one of the perks of samuel
365 is you get a property mentor it's
like an insurance policy for property
mentors so
basically anytime you want any question
any deal anything at all
you can just go on the samuel 36
platform six platform
um book in a call with one of our
property mentors
pick the topic so you get an expert in
that field
give them a call uh a time that suits
you
and they'll go through anything with you
anything that you want um
so it really is an invaluable service i
would say especially if you've got a
deal going through and you want to run
it over with someone yeah you can speak
to one of the mentors about it pick
their brain go over it come with
questions and we'll talk to you on a one
on one basis that's part of samuel 365
service let's get down to business i've
been stripped from everything so i'm
starting all over again from
scratch this is like a really important
view you're gonna be using an alias name
i think you made it really hard for
yourself i probably wouldn't do it
no car no money we've been kicked out of
the networking event
if i haven't made any money in the next
seven days i will be evicted from my
hotel and be on the streets
we just nibble on them for the week i've
got 50 pound in my pocket for basic
potentials i'm not eating today at all
it'll be in the back
but i need to start building my property
portfolio again from scratch with
nothing let's see what happens
within two weeks i've never seen
anything like this before i'm
documenting everything this is the
financial freedom challenge